good afternoon everyone
welcome to this simultaneous meeting of
baylor district council cabinet and mit
suffolk district council cabinet
i'm councillor john ward leader of baby
district council and also in attendance
is councillor susie morley
leader of mid-suffolk district council
we will jointly
be chairing the meeting today however
for reasons of efficiency i will be
leading the items
may i remind you of some domestic
arrangements please ensure that
microphones are turned off when not in
use
please do not interrupt other speakers
if you are attending the meeting to
speak and persistently interrupt the
meeting you may be asked to leave
please remember to use the chat function
only to indicate that you wish to speak
and not to post comments or questions
please note that messages in the chat
panel
can be viewed by people watching the
live broadcast
i would like to remind everyone present
that this meeting will be broadcast live
to the internet
and will be capable of repeated viewing
the whole of the meeting will be filmed
except where there are confidential or
exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
filmed
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you are also consenting to being
recorded by the council and to the
possible use of those images
and sound recordings for webcasting and
or training purposes
the council members of the public and
the press may record film photograph or
broadcast this meeting
when the public and the press are not
lawfully excluded
i will now ask the governance officer to
carry out the introductions
thank you chair the following officers
are joining us today
strategic director kathy nixon deputy
monitoring officer
jan robinson assistant director for
environment and commercial partnerships
cassandra clements the corporate manager
for public realm planning and
communities
bill burchnell and professional lead for
key sites and infrastructure christine
furlow
in addition to the cabinet members we
also have the following councillors
today
councillor alastair mccraw councillor
robert lindsey
councillor rachel ebern councillor john
field
councillor andrew mellon and councillor
keith welland
thank you thank you claire can i now
move to the agenda please
item one apologies for absence and i'll
now ask the government's officer
to roll call for the members present
thank you councillors if you could
confirm your attendance when i call your
name
uh councillor alfie president
councillor busby president councillor
davis
president councillor halt president
councillor melvisi present
councillor osborne present
councillor parker present
council award present thank you
councillor brewster
councillor flatman present councillor
fleming president
councillor gould present councillor
hattingham
present councillor morley present
councillor richardson present and
councillor whitehead
present thank you chair thank you
item two to receive declarations of
pecuniary and non-pecuniary interests by
members
are there any to declare
no right item three then
paper bca204
confirmation of the minutes of the
meeting of the baba cabinet held on the
28th of september 2020
are there any points regarding the
accuracy of these minutes now they're
in your gender pack on pages seven to
ten
nope well i'm happy to propose those
may i have a second to please
chairman clive arthur i'll second thank
you
um and i've now asked the governance
officer to conduct
a vote for the minutes you chair
councillor alfie four councillor busby
councillor davis
poor councillor holt i'll abstain i
wasn't present
councillor malvisi four
councillor osborne four councillor
parker
paul council
thank you chair that's carried thank you
and next is paper mca
2004 confirmation of the minutes of the
meeting of the mid-socket cabinet held
on the 28th of september
are there any points regarding the
accuracy of these minutes
in which case may i have a proposal
please
uh chair i will i'm happy to propose the
minutes
thank you castle gould a second to
please and chair i'm happy to second
those minutes
thank you council flatman and uh now i'd
like the governance officer to conduct
the vote please thank you chair
councillor brewster
richardson paul councillor whitehead
four thank you chair that's carried
thank you
next item four paper bca205
confirmation of the minutes of the
meeting of the baba cabinet held on the
5th of october
and these are on pages 11 to 12 of your
agenda pack
are there any points regarding the
accuracy of these minutes
uh okay in which case i'd like to
propose them may i have a second to
please
i'm willing to sec uh to second it
thank you councilman thank you and now
um can we have the the vote please thank
you
counci for
councillor busby councillor davis
councillor davis
thank you councillor halt
councillor melvisi four councillor
osborne
four councillor parker four
council award four thank you to the
chair that's carried
thank you nexus paper mca mca205
confirmation of the minutes of the
meeting of the mid-suffolk cabinet
held on the 5th of october and on your
agenda pack they're on pages
11 to 14. are there any points regarding
the accuracy please
okay may i have a proposal again chair
i'm happy to
propose the minutes thank you castle
gold and the seconder
and again i'm happy to promote at a
second the minutes
thank you council flatman okay can we
have uh the vote now please
thank you councillor brewster paul
councillor burn four councillor flatman
or councillor fleming
four councillor richardson um i should
abstain as i was present
thank you and councillor whitehead four
thank you chair that's carried thank you
now the minutes of these meetings have
been confirmed and they will be signed
at the next practical opportunity
moving on to item five to receive
notification of petitions in accordance
with the council's petition scheme
do we have any
sorry chair not received thank you
item 6 questions by councillors
chair we have questions from councillor
robert lindsey and councillor daniel
pratt
thank you i'll now invite councillor
lindsay to ask his questions to the
cabinet member for the environment
thank you chair um i've got
three questions if i may on the
biodiversity thing but first just to say
thanks to um to everyone involved i
thought it was a very positive
series of meetings and clear consensus
that we all wanted
stuff done and posit
particularly to cassandra the the the
officer
in charge there um so there's lots of
stuff
that i really like in this report about
all of it i really like
um it was just to um there there's a few
bits
that are seem to be seem to be missing
that we
discussed so number one was um well prep
not missing but it talks about meadow
planting
and i know this sounds like semantics
but i um
i thought the thruster argument was that
meadow planting isn't really what we're
really talking about is meadow
management um because if we're if we're
talking about
planting up meadows it often means
spraying a load of glyphosate
to kill off the grass that is there and
you actually lose some biodiversity
potentially by doing that far better to
manage it
by mowing less frequently in taking the
cuttings
so that was just a plea can we change
the wording to meadow management when we
talk about that that was number one and
number two was um
that i didn't see anything about i
thought we discussed about removing
glyphosate hundred percent from council
use um and i
and i think we should do that and i
think we should also
publicize the fact that we're doing it
if we want to encourage
um farmers and uh non and domestic
users of glyphosate stop using it so
um uh what's happened to the
the plan to phase out glyphosate and do
we have a plan to publicize the fact
we're doing it
that's number two and number three um
we heard about that all the work that
was done with the hedgerow survey
and there were plans to digitize it but
what's happened with those plans
is there a timetable or someone assigned
to
to digitize the hedgerow survey thank
you
thank you council lindsay councillor
malvisi would you like to
respond thank you
with regard to the gla if i pronounce it
correctly
glycol glyphosate glycogen
glyphosate glyphosate that's it okay
um we are reducing its use
in fact i'm not sure that we actually
use it at all anymore
um i think i'll call on cassandra
clements to confirm that please
hello there yes so um we spoke to the
biodiversity
task force about the use of um
glyphosate nearly got my tongue twisted
then as well
um and it was actually a very low liters
of it used within the council and we
absolutely
did agree councillor lindsay that we
would stop using glyphosate across both
districts
um so there has been a short trial of
another um another weed killer
uh which i know uh will burst on the
call as well if you wanted some
further detail during cabinet on that
that's all been working brilliantly
that's an acid based weed killer and so
we are ready to push ahead now with um
removing glyphosate completely
from both districts and absolutely agree
that we should do
some great pr on that
can i just quickly ask i didn't catch it
was a something based weed killer i
didn't catch the word
it's acetic acid an acid-based weed
killer
acid-based weaker okay thank you robert
i think it's based on acetic acid acetic
acid vinegar
vinegar yes vinegar okay thank you
so when instead of putting it on your
chips you go out and put it on your
weeds
yummy and they have the other two
questions
yeah on the meadow planting um
we were talking about meadow verges
not actually creating meadows
per se
yeah so the same question applies really
because if you manage the verges
with by uh removing the cuttings and
there's not necessarily a need to
replant is what i'm saying
no but we wouldn't be using
glyphosate did i get that right
uh we wouldn't be using glyphosate to
reduce
the grasses in order to be able to plant
the meadow verges we'd be using the
acetic acid
which is the vinegar and removing i mean
if if the timing is right
you get the grasses cut down and then
removed and then you plant the the um
as they call them flowers for bees or
something that's being advertised
and then you pre you know that generates
your um your meadow verge
um does that answer your question no
um well i don't want to hold everyone up
but it's just
i think it's not neces
it's not in every situation it's not
necessary i wouldn't have thought
to actually remove the vegetation that's
there no that's right in some cases
right you don't even need to do that you
may need a little bit of sowing of some
some seeds but not not a complete
you don't need to kill off what's there
and i'd have thought
as a principle we ought to say you know
by default we don't kill it off unless
there's unless we know that
that we can't establish that habitat any
other way
but in order to think sorry
council lindsay will cut and collect to
gradually reduce the fertility
over time yeah and you're looking at
we're looking at acquiring uh a
dedicated mower for that
cassandra highlight yes sorry so i'd
jump in
and help a little here um absolutely
that the uh specifics we were talking
around at one point were around
meadow verges but uh councillor lindsay
is right that the term for
um anything of that kind is actually
meadow management so my apologies for
the
the incorrection in the in the report so
essentially meadow management is simply
covering
that um you will look at the the
nature of the piece of land and act
appropriately
so rather than just saying planting
because it might not be appropriate to
plant and it's about meadow management
so i apologize that's an incorrect uh
word use
from me okay um
councillor lindsay your next question
what was the digitization of the
of the uh survey
[Music]
right well that's actually quite a long
convoluted
task um and i think there is a consensus
that perhaps we could
maybe utilize the services
of some students to digitize um
but it's not been dismissed it is there
it is planned um
so i hope that allays any fears that you
have
okay we don't have a timetable then by
the sound of it
no we don't because i think it's going
to take some time to actually quantify
um
i think it's a case of actually i mean
as ridiculous as it sounds in 2020
we're going to have to get the boxes of
the papers
count the papers and work out how long
it's actually going to take to digitize
so we are not dismissing it because it's
invaluable information and invaluable
resources once it's digitized
but the mapping goes ahead and that
hopefully will run parallel but to the
side
your third question i think i think
we've done them all now thank you
okay thank you okay thank you
for that um next we'll move on to
um counselor melon
uh i believe is now going to ask
questions on behalf of councillor pratt
um who is unable to attend this
afternoon and that will be to the
cabinet member for environment
at mid suffolk um councillor mellon can
you
stick to the the questions as they were
originally submitted please um
certainly can share um to be honest they
are pretty much identical to the
questions
that um robert lindsay has asked so i
don't think we need to proceed with them
okay right um thank you for that
um uh interesting questions and i think
they will
help um uh certainly um from the the
perspective
of the um uh the digitizing the hedgerow
survey i
i have actually heard that um will
birchnau will be carrying out this task
um
and we'll be using the uh
suffolk biodiversity information service
to to assist and
and to um hold that information
uh cassandra did you want to come in on
that
hello yes sir it's just to confirm on
that last point that uh will birchna
absolutely has taken the action
to look into the hedgerow digitalization
surveys
um he is two prongs really
we are looking at whether we can use
apprentices to do that
um but we are also going to get a quote
through suffolk information services as
well
um in case that doesn't come through so
there may be a cost to it but we're
hoping to be able to do that a different
way
okay that's brilliant thank you um i'd
like to just point out
at this stage we must be careful not to
demonize glyphosate too much
um the uh the manufacturer of the
acetic acid based alternative
does actually um quote that it's i ideal
to use
um in rotation with glyphosate and we
must also realize
that glyphosate does it is a systemic
weak killer unlike acetic acid which
just operates on the foliage
and um it is broken down quite quickly
on contact with the ground acetic acid
is also only
ideal for hard surfaces rather than um
open countryside and it does have a
potential um
harmful impact on reptiles and
amphibians so we need to
we need to be careful on this uh
councillor fleming you have your hand up
yes i i just um i had put my hand up in
response to the question about the hedge
survey
and i just wanted to add that um we've
been having conversations with will
burchill and
because this is a suffolk wide set of
data
we clearly need to work with our other
local authority partners to get this
done
and that's exactly what we intend to do
how we approach getting the data out of
it and digitizing it needs to be
consistent across the county
and the data that we get out or abstract
needs to be in a um a usable and useful
format so it's not something you just go
for helpful leather at
it needs a bit of thought and
coordination and that's exactly what
we're doing
thank you castle for me okay then moving
on item seven
matters are referred by the overview and
scrutiny or joint audit and standards
committees
there were unchair thank you item eight
the forthcoming decisions list
um you've all been provided with the uh
the link to the latest
forthcoming decisions list does anyone
have any comments please
okay in which case we'll move on to item
nine
and this is paper bca2006 and
mca206 the biodiversity task force
proposals the cabinet now for baber this
is on pages 13 to 46 of your agenda pack
for mid suffolk on pages 15 to 48
of your agenda pack i'll now invite the
baba cabinet member for the environment
to introduce the baba report
good afternoon and thank you chair um
i am laying before cabinet
a motion that the biodiversity action
plan is created
by the biodiversity task force be
adopted
by baber that the biodiversity task
force group continued to meet to monitor
the action plan and consider new ideas
for increasing biodiversity
some time ago you recognize the
increasing pace
with which our natural habitat is being
decimated
and that it too has now become an
emergency but a biodiversity one
since then the national trust has
announced they're going to
fell some 40 000 trees
because of ash dieback and by 2100
or 2100 we will have destroyed some 24
percent if not more of
our wildlife the impact
of that on us or those of us left is
unimaginable
the ecosystem will itself be decimated
biodiversity for our in our district
doesn't sit in isolation it's
intrinsically intertwined
into our lives
and the world's into our climate and the
world's climate
you must remember as a child being told
that if a butterfly flapped its wings in
beijing then new york would have a
cyclone
and that's true because the felling of
trees in the amazon forest
is causing massive damage to climate
and changing it globally but if we all
start doing something positive to
protect
and enhance our own ecosystem then the
fight back starts
it's therefore imperative that we work
towards a system
where we enable a net biodiversity gain
there are some who've written to the
media demonstrating a lack of some
pretty fundamental principles
that in order to solve a problem you
have to go back to the original
you have to retrace your steps to see
where it went wrong
we're all in this together this first
piece of work is only
part of what's needed to be done
a joined up collective effort from
everyone
and if anyone wants to contribute to the
mapping
planning delivery of councils
biodiversity aspirations
they're very welcome
we're asking you to enable us to conduct
the survey that will assist us to map
our nature
reserves and wildlife sites
identify the wildlife corridors that
exist which in turn
will identify where we are lacking and
need to focus
there are voices that ask for this map
to go public
public consultation but to what end the
map
is to determine what we've got
because right now we don't know what
we've got
and that sounds pretty shocking existing
wildlife corridors can be enhanced and
strengthened
by either reinstalling hedgerows in the
correct areas or by planting the correct
trees
again in the correct areas thus creating
an oasis of
biodiversity this map though will be
multi-purpose
since it will provide our planners with
definitive data
to enable them to build back better
and help them make the necessary value
judgments in the planning process
the map which will be available to the
public
will assist the districts to develop
eco-tourism
thereby attracting much-needed tourist
revenue to the region
which hopefully then we can plow back to
develop
our flower meadow verges changing
our management techniques to stifle the
growth of grasses
and encourage wildflower growth provide
habitat for bees butterflies and other
insects
necessary to maintain a balanced
ecosystem
the task force continues to be committed
to the trees for life scheme
providing native locally sourced and
grown trees
naturally everything the task force has
worked on
and put into action plan could not have
been done without the invaluable
expertise and help from simone bullion
of the south wide
south of the suffolk's wildlife
trust sue hooten of place services
david hughes andy graham martin sanford
at suffolk biodiversity
information service and last but not
least
kathy oberton without whom we would have
got
totally lost in the volume of
information and
data and of course maybe last but most
definitely not least
the never-ending support from cassandra
clements
and her team a huge thank you
it must be recognized that the cost of
maintaining and
improving the biodiversity of our area
must be budgeted for moving forwards the
creation of a wildlife network
map will allow us to quantify the effort
required
to improve biodiversity across the
region
and allow us to target funding to those
areas most in need
and in agreeing you are further
endorsing
the lead environmental position
of both baba and mid suffolk
in the county of suffolk i recommend
this motion to you thank you
chair
has everybody frozen uh
no councilmember bc i don't believe so
we've uh seemed to have lost the
chair council award
gosh sorry i'm here yes i did what
happened then
um right put you to sleep
no no not at all thank you council
malvisi um may i have a second
from baber
i'll be happy to second that myself um
and now i'll invite the mid suffolk
cabinet member for the environment
to introduce the mid suffolk report
councillor fleming
well thank you thank you chairman thank
you everybody
um good afternoon um i am delighted to
introduce
this paper which presents the work of
the biodiversity task group
in the form of actions designed to put
into place real safeguards
for the wider environment and
biodiversity with it
at its center in addition to the task
group members and offices the actions
in it are the results of invaluable
input and advice from suffolk wildlife
trust um simone bullion and essex county
council's principal ecologist sue hooton
without these people the actions would
not be supported by a technical proposal
for ecological mapping
of the standard that we have before us
we are extremely fortunate to have
enjoyed their company and advice
throughout the meetings and to have
received a proposal that is targeted to
our own specific needs
you will find the proposal from suffolk
wildlife trust and the suffolk
biological
information center in appendix c and i
do hope everyone's had a chance to read
through it
it's called understanding the district's
biodiversity resources
the actions that are before us are
important first
steps to enable the districts to take
the environment
seriously and by this i mean recognizing
that monetary investment and some form
of restraint on human activity
are necessary in order to understand
and keep wild areas for species other
than ourselves
no pain no gain so to speak natural
resources and by that i really mean
natural capital
is finite and in order to continue to
live in a sustainable and civilized way
humans must also recognize their own
limits
and i'm very pleased that perhaps for
the first time
this paper commits real investment to
the environment
i have just mentioned the need to
understand what we've got
and establish a baseline the work that
is proposed will not only do that for
the districts
but also it will feed into wider work on
biodiversity that is important
to both sbis and to defra in defining a
national baseline
from which to measure net gain one of
the key tenants of the environment bill
you will see that one of the outcomes of
the swt
work is to return data to defra and to
gather information on county and local
wildlife
sites particularly those where
information is lacking
there are over 400 sites in both
districts
23 and baber and 31 in mid suffolk
are severely lacking in information
anyone who doubts that action on
biodiversity is urgent
should read the state of natural capital
report
issued by central government
issued earlier this year by the natural
capital committee
and i'm going to make a couple of quotes
from it
the natural environment is deteriorating
the government's first report on
progress
against the 25-year environmental pub
plan published last year
provides a long list of actions and very
little evidence of improvement
in the state of england's natural
capital
this failure is due in large part to the
lack
of a baseline against which to measure
progress
with reference to the biodiversity net
gain measure in the environment bill
the ncc goes on to say only an
environmental
net gain approach in planning and
development
will ensure that aggregate natural
capital
is maintained and enhanced
here i refer to the next most important
action in my opinion
which is to work with our strategic
planning
officers and develop a supplementary
planning document to strengthen the
protections for the
biodiversity within the planning system
introduce a local approach to achieving
biodiversity net gain
pending of course passage of the
environment bill into law
and completion of the joint local plan
information from the mapping work will
be crucial
to implementing this action and i
greatly look forward to working
with our planning team in the task group
on this project
next year in conclusion
a huge thank you to all those who have
put their time and effort
into the work to date in particular to
cass
and her team who has been with us
throughout
and to our partners who i've just
mentioned
partnership working across suffolk and
the region will be crucial to the
success
of this program we are committed to this
across the board but to start the
process your approval is necessary today
and i ask that all cabinet members
please endorse the recommendations
in the cabinet report thank you
thank you councillor fleming may i have
a second definite suffer please
counselor burn thank you very much thank
you
right i will now move into questions on
the the content
of the paper before we move into debate
so firstly questions from baba members
um i'll go through each in turn uh to
see if you have any questions counselor
arthi
no thank you very much i was part of the
task force so i've had my input
thank you okay counselor busby
yeah well greenway is considered uh
as possible consultants for the mapping
cat can you pick up on that
hello chair um we were um talking with
um simone simon bullion from suffolk
wildlife trust because
of uh some other survey work that
they're doing already that we believe we
can
um we can go on the back of so
we hadn't considered anybody at that
point um
happy to absolutely look at greenways
for any further survey work because i'm
sure there's going to be much more
uh but we were hoping to um jump in on
the back of some other work that
suffolk wildlife trust were already
doing
thank you mention it because they they
manage the
bastard brook park which is a huge the
huge green lung between ipswich and the
a14
um it would be crazy to have
that work duplicated i'm not certain
they've got the whole place mapped but
they'll certainly know
what areas what sure we'll make sure
that there's no duplication we'll
certainly get in touch with them that's
for sure and we're very happy to be
uh sharing our information out as the
the portfolio holders have said so i'm
sure we can work with them
thank you um moving down the list
councillor davis do you have any
questions
at this point i just i just want to
commend the paper i think it's an
excellent piece of work
i followed it all along and um had
various inputs so
i think it's uh excellent thank you
councillor holt
no question john thank you councilman
melvici
well i don't suppose you've got any
questions
uh councillor osborne thank you mr
chairman um yeah i do have a question
um first of all well done to the task
force i think they've done an excellent
job
i think this is a big way forward for
all councillors and all officers so
well done to everybody concerned really
positive news story um
my question is on page 17 of the report
where it's got
financial implications it refers to baba
that it will cost
147 350
and some of that is going to be coming
from the hra account
do we know how much have we got an
estimation of how much is going to come
from the hra account
you like me to please sure um at the
moment
uh i've been talking with uh the
assistant director for housing gavin
fisk
on what biodiversity actions could
happen
within um within the housing area so
we're at very early days for that
um i know they've got some huge
aspirations to play a big part of this
role
and so at the moment we haven't got any
um
plans that have got um a financial plan
to them
but absolutely we can bring that to you
as soon as we've we've developed that
thank you cassandra can i just come back
on that mr chairman and also for members
of the public
that are listening in i apologize hra is
housing revenue account
thank you mr chairman thank you council
osborne councillor parker do you have
any questions
uh not at this stage chair thank you
okay
thank you moving on to the mid suffolk
members castle brewster
um yes i i too think this is a
and very essential to to get in place um
however i do have three questions
the first one can be
on at uh 4.17
on page 18 of the agenda
uh labor is having 10
300 only 2 500 recorded trees
seeing that these are all cancelled
and i put that question to
uh councillor fleming
um so um councillor brewster
you faded away during that and i didn't
and um he was asking about the numbers
of trees that it refers to in
in that paragraph um that
i think um council bruce said the
discrepancy between the babe and
mid-suffolk numbers
that's right yes indeed there's a big
big difference
recorded trees you know i i think that
must be on cancer
and land and um recorded trees on castle
and that's
i don't think it is a terribly
meaningful paragraph in terms of the
relative
woodedness of the two districts so i
wouldn't
be too upset over over it actually i
think there's a ready explanation
somewhere
does that help or should we go to
someone in the uh an officer for a
further explanation
cass can you elaborate
on the treatment thank you so i think
there's a slight delay counselor
brewster on your video and so we
we were getting a bit of your question
um every now and again
so just to to confirm that that uh
that number is about council owned trees
only on our land
um and also what um what generally
happens with tree counting is that
clusters are quite often counted as one
so it doesn't mean there are only two
and a half thousand trees but
um often in um in tree counting it
it's just the way they are um added to
the mapping system
so there are likely to be more than two
and a half thousand but in terms of
um the way we account for trees that's
uh that's the number for mid suffolk
okay thank you and
uh question two uh
page 24. i hope you're hearing me better
now
yes my hearing it's it's improving yes
yeah yeah just just how much
consultation
cancels regarding tree piping in their
areas
and how many what could prove to be
quite expensive free maintenance
on those trees
owned by mid southwark
um so your question is
how much consultation will take place on
tree planting
remember how much
parish councils and how many have agreed
to carry out
what could prove to be quite expensive
three main trees owned by mid suffolk
okay um we have put out a what i would
call it a sort of
a testing email to all parish councils
to um so to gauge
interest in tree and hedge planting
in general and we've had responses from
i would say about a quarter of the
parish councils
who were contacted um with interest
we have really not got farther than that
because we need to get this cabinet
paper approved
and then we intend to um collate the
results and get back to the parish
councils who have expressed interest and
follow-up
and be more specific about where and
what
they might have in mind it could be on
parish council-owned land it could also
be on land that
the parish council is aware might be
receptive to having additional planting
and in fact you know we hope to broaden
that as these actions go forward to
working with farmers with other
organizations such as um
cla and nfu to try and bring farmers
into the scheme as well
so you know as i think we've said this
is at an early stage
and um we we're going to take this
forward
now we do realize it's a financial
commitment and the cost of tree planting
you'll probably see
is the highest cost in the action list
um i think the district intends to
maintain the trees for about a year but
it will eventually be something that
communities will be willing to have to
take on themselves does that provide
better explanation
thank you
um we are having problems with your
connection
okay i'll leave the last
okay
[Music]
um thank you castle bruce i assume you
said you you're going to
uh i just not asked the last question
if you could follow it up um counselor
brewster with an email i'll i'll
respond to it i'll take it at a meeting
thank you
thank you thank you moving on councilor
brewster could turn off his incoming
video and that may make the connection a
bit better
thank you councilman yeah
councillor byrne do you have any
questions uh yes
thank you very much um
uh i very much welcome the the task
force's
action plan and it's very reassuring to
see that the
first proposal on the list concerns
mapping the district's habitat assets
as a basis for understanding how our
wildlife habitat
network might be improved and hopefully
enlarged
um i'm sure that this pole position in
the document
is not necessarily a statement of
priority
despite the fact that it's fairly
fundamental to
uh the rest of uh the rest of the uh
action plan um partly because
as as with so many aspects of ecology
all the proposals in the action plan
interlink
and it will take time for us to
understand their
individual contributions to the whole
even so the mapping component as i say
must be close to the basis of developing
the understanding
the proposal talks of collaborating with
partners
and with so many groups and
organizations sharing the common aims of
safeguarding of our um biodiversity
my specific question is is there yet
a working protocol for integrating what
we
do with the efforts of others across the
county
um thank you very much councillor bern
there is as you know the suffolk climate
change committee so
at the climate change and there is
a framework set up for the districts and
boroughs to
periodically meet discuss common
programs and collaborate
there is not a formal program set up
that is equivalent for biodiversity it
may
be that biodiversity rolls into the
committee that's already existed under
the county council cabinet member
richard routt
um i would expect that that was probably
where it will go
um because there is definitely a need
for collaboration and
we don't want to be tripping over each
other doing the same thing
or um doing things that are um
that are similar but don't quite match
up and
and that's particularly relevant to the
hedge survey for instance which we
discussed earlier today where
it is obviously important that we
collaborate across the county
the data are county-wide and we need to
address it on a county-wide basis i
believe um
will burchill has already been speaking
with suffolk county council about that
and about other ways we can collaborate
at a county-wide basis
um there are there are so many ways we
can and have started to collaborate um
counselor
for instance i've already been speaking
with someone from
[Music]
as you probably know the distant
district neighborhood plan about
collaboration
in the upper wavenew valley and
i think that um yes we will be
collaborating with
stakeholders like suffolk by
biodiversity information
service and with suffolk wildlife trust
and with our district and borough
partners
so absolutely yes it's vital to the
success of this program
thank you council fleming okay
councillor flatman do you have any
questions
uh just to say that um firstly i welcome
the report
and would like to thank the task force
and the officers for what they have
already achieved in bringing this
forward
and i know it's very early days and
working with our partners as yes key
but also i was really pleased to see the
early engagement with the town and
parish councils
who have local knowledge of land and
possible sites
which could be brought forward but also
once once this gets
underway i'd really like love to see the
schools involved
so bring it home to their own gardens
with less mowing in the summer
and perhaps we could run a competition
with the
parish councils and um town councils and
perhaps there could be a prize
i don't know it it would just make them
go home and say
you cannot mow you cannot know you know
and they would all be doing their little
bit so i think that is something perhaps
we could take forward um later on in the
um process i think that's a
councillor flatman that's a brilliant um
suggestion
and um i've already been thinking that
maybe we could start schools
um you know growing some trees from seed
some based on local seed that will
obviously do well in suffolk because
they're born and raised here
and i think it would be a great way to
get children um you know
seeing little oak trees and maybe ash
trees sprouting out and and planting
them themselves so
absolutely yes lots to look forward to
excellent thank you okay
uh thanks for that uh moving on
councillor gould you very much
uh check yeah um a couple of uh
questions if i may uh like everyone else
i very much uh applaud uh
this report and the proposals in it not
least because
of their immense practicality in terms
they are things which are immensely
immensely doable uh
but there is an issue there that um and
i just wanted some reassurance i guess
on the on the financing of those
proposals
there is a degree of interdependence uh
between
the councils in terms of delivery and
obviously it requires
i assume i'm writing thinking that it
requires the commitment to both councils
to enable us uh to fully implement
implement the plan there's the second
is really um a suggestion posing is a
question
really uh and like councillor flatman i
uh applaud the uh involvement of town
and parish councils in this
and and my point is about uh
green burial sites um about she's
mentioned at
para 421 in the report and
a desire to to seek out uh such
sites well my suggestion is that uh
i-town council
has in the town cemetery an
area which is being defined as a green
burial site
but there is no there's been no
investment no ability
to actually develop this site or its
potential
to make it suitable but i just wanted to
to put that on the radar
um thank you very much
thank you council gould um yes thank you
is that in in terms of the finance
between the councils i'm really not in a
position to
um to respond on that i i believe that
if there's a will there's a way and um
that money will be found um to do this
work because it's important
in terms of green burial um i have
actually had a word with our local
bishop
um there with our bishop mike and i
believe there is an archdiocesan
diocesan nominee for
such things as environment
improving biodiversity in graveyards and
green burials
i believe that he is on temporary
leave at the moment but i think
eventually we will be able to make
contact with the diocese
and work as one avenue to work um
you know on that um point but um through
it so really to any
anyone who has ideas or contacts is
welcome to suggest them
so thank you council fleming um if i can
just
uh come back on the the issue of the the
funding of
of these items um council ghoul that
there are clearly
some that uh require the uh cooperation
of the two councils and some which
uh can be considered to be items that
each council can
effectively do on their own to a greater
or lesser extent
things such as the mapping um the
uh the planning supplementary planning
document
uh the biodiversity campaign and
the um purchase of a cut and collect
mower
are things that we will have to do
together um and
looking at the sums involved um although
i think
probably at the back of your mind um
there's the baba
general fund situation but i think we
can
safely assume that we will find the
funding for those
items certainly at baba because they are
essential for this to to make progress
and uh without doing that uh we we won't
be able to
achieve any of the action plans so um
i i think you can um be reassured that
that those items
at least uh we'll be able to we'll be
able to proceed with those
quickly um to make make progress on on
the action plan
thank you chair i appreciate that you
answered part of the question i didn't
ask but i
very much appreciate that thank you i
kind of thought that
anyway that's good um moving on
councillor hanningham
um thank you yeah i just want to say um
to to cast
you know fantastic report um but i have
got one question
i'm particularly excited about the
colorful verges because i think hey
you know you know we all need more
beauty in our life
and um and i think it's very achievable
and on page 48 you've got a list of um
where you say that they're the first
ones that you've identified but
i'll just let you know that a how many
are you going to start with and how soon
will you be able to roll it out
to more areas
um thank you councillor hattingham i'm
hoping that when the verge cutting
season begins next summer that we will
be rolling this
out but we obviously need to work
um with the county council and with
contractors
on verges that aren't completely in the
control of the districts
in terms of our own district
owned and operated verges um that's not
such a problem
but um i would guess next summer we will
start to change and hopefully we'll have
the um
cut and collect mower by then cool
so have you got you know you're just
going to start it sort of pretty much
ever like not just the ones that you've
identified are you going to just
you know go for the for frankly most of
um mid suffolk then are you
we're going i'll hand over to cass to um
elaborate on that hello thank you so
um we we based our presentation of this
on
um some case studies that the task force
brought forward themselves actually on
another council that have done this
and they very much spoke to us about
doing trial
sites first to make sure you know what
you're doing for a season
before you go ahead and roll out so
what's presented to you in appendix e
on on 48 of your gender pack um are
these sites that we would like to do as
the trial
so we will run that for a season and
then we'll be able to have some evidence
from that to see how it's going and what
we need to do
and then what impact that would have so
there may be some
further equipment needed there may be
more mowers needed to roll out
across the across the districts and we
can come back to cabinet and
present that to you but this is for one
season's worth
of um trial areas okay cool thanks very
much
thank you thank you councillor morley
is that thank you chair i've i've got a
question i suspect it's probably for
cass but
i'll leave it up to you to decide on
page 24
of the report appendix a under the
section on tree and hedge planting i
wonder if you could just elaborate a bit
on the the cost of the trees
and the distinction between the actual
cost of planting
versus the cost of maintenance and
at what point do those trees and
hedgerows start to becoming
productive in terms of of carbon take up
i wonder if you could just elaborate on
that a little bit thank you absolutely i
can thank you very much
um councillor morley so um
this is the tree in hedge planting
action in appendix a
and what you can see there so the
numbers are the same for both
mid-suffolk and baber and i've split
them into two
so what you will see is an amount of 72
500 for trees or hedges now what i have
done
is base that on um a
tree costing 145
pounds um the total amount of trees of
500
145 pounds each and that tree is
a local tree of an age that it has an
impact immediately so as all councillors
i'm sure will absolutely know
um for instance trees for life trees are
only around seven pounds each and
they're very young
and it will take some years for them to
start having an
impact so what we've done here is pitch
this in a way that
in year one of this plan we plant trees
that immediately have an impact on our
districts
so that's um that is the cost of the
tree itself so a capital cost
and then underneath you'll see that 32
000 pounds
and that is very much about the revenue
cost associated with those trees
moving forward so that will include the
labor of planting them in the first
place but it will always also include
an element of inspection and maintenance
on them so you have a capital cost there
and a revenue cost there so of course
that's a sliding scale
if you want younger trees that will take
a little bit longer to have an impact
but they're cheaper
that's fine we can do that and also
there may be areas that
um tree planting isn't appropriate and
hedge funding might be
so this is if you think of it this is
the least
get with that money with a big tree but
of course that money could be spread
further if you have different trees or
hedges
thank you very much thank you can i just
add that
in terms of carbon and climate change
um in terms of co2 emissions you know
trees
obviously use co2 in photosynthesis
but they don't have leaves all year
round
so um you know planting trees is
wonderful and benefits the environment
an enormous number of ways
but in terms of um combating climate
change they're probably not
um you know the number one sort of
item on the on your agenda to reduce
our emissions because they won't buy
very much
okay thank you thank you
um councillor whitehead any questions
from you
oh yes thank you um first of all yeah
excellent report
i too was really surprised at the
contrast between the number of trees
recorded in baber and suffolk you know
four to one ratio
because i assume trees in the district
covered by tpos
are covered within this recorded trees
as these are presumably the most
important trees and i guess
by definition they're on the record and
so that's is that assumption correct but
also my question is
are we going to do more to encourage
more trees to come under the tpo regime
going forward
um i i have a feeling the answer is no
but i would
refer again to cass on that
hello there so um on the number of tpo
trees
um absolutely we're here to help if
anyone believes that a tree should have
a tpo
on them and i think there is that
this is a really tough one to answer
because they they are clear
there is clearly um a lot of passion out
there for the trees that we have in our
districts
but there is also conversely very strict
criteria for a tree to meet a tree
preservation order
and so the amount of work it would take
to go out and check every single tree to
see whether it should have a
tree preservation order on it is quite
considerable um
what we can promise is that if people do
come to us with
um the thought that a tree might need a
tpo that it absolutely does get
inspected and it does get inspected
quickly and we can start that process um
but i'm not sure my
colleagues in the planning service would
thank me for
for saying that that's a piece of work
that we should start doing because it is
incredibly difficult and
and takes a lot of time to do
um and i i think it's just right for me
to acknowledge that i know
a lot of people have frustrations with
that criteria because quite often a tree
isn't
in danger until it's in danger um and so
what i do think we need to do is make
sure we get right the protocol that if
someone is worried about something
happening to a tree that shouldn't be
that we get that part right at the very
least
yeah thank you guys thank you thank you
right okay um do any other members of
the
either council present have a any
further questions that they wish to ask
at this point if so can you indicate in
in the the chat pane councillor wellan
thank you chair yeah i've got i've got
three questions
um yeah i can understand the need for
the supplementary planning
document um then this will be very
useful in the longer term
but is it not possible to make to make a
start
in respect of open spaces on new
developments
could planning offices be asked to sink
meadows orchards tree planted areas and
so on instead of the manicured open
spaces and balancing ponds
that we see on developments there's a
real opportunity to start
this early on with dialogue with the
developers at pre-application stage
so can that be encouraged please um
i've got a question about the page on
page 27
yeah i was i was pleased to hear um
councillor flatman
um talk about schools but is it not
possible that we could get something
ready for schools in the shorter term
i'm sure i'm not the only member who's
asked by schools
what they can do so is there some sort
of off-the-shelf
advice that can be um sort of downloaded
or provided
things like how to make a bird box
advice about hedgehogs and how they
should be allowed to go from one garden
to another
and perhaps wildflower areas in in
school gardens and even at home ways of
attracting
bees and and what fertilizer and weed
killer
is suitable for use and what should not
be used
and the third question on page 35
i noticed that there are 600 public
realm sites in baber
but only 70 in mid-suffolk um
and i wondered if that's because some of
the open space in council
housing areas in babur are classed as
public realm sites but not so in
mid-south i wonder if there's a
difference in the way that that that
open space has been classified
thank you councilor wellam um before i
ask either
uh councillor fleming or cass to respond
to those three
um i take the point that you make about
schools um and and provision of
information
but we don't want to duplicate what can
be provided
um very in very good form um
elsewhere whether it's through various
uh
wildlife organizations uh bbc or
whatever
um we want to focus our our effort and
our money
on uh providing information assistance
um that's specific to to this particular
action plan and
and to what we need in our district so i
certainly don't want to be um
replicating replicating advice on
on bird boxes or or um hedgehog habitats
or whatever that
perfectly uh readily available elsewhere
but um councillor fleming
did you want to come back to
councilwoman yes
thank you very much um both of you um i
just like to um
i think i think um your point counselor
wallam on
developers and how we can improve um on
that score is is very well taken we did
i think we did discuss that quite a bit
in our meetings and i think
um education of um
more communication with developers early
is something that we want to instigate
as well
which is possibly even
involving some of our main developers in
some
communication workshops on biodiversity
so that they are aware before they even
put in an application of what our
expectation is
and this is something i believe we don't
need an spd
to do um we can do that right now and
it's probably something we should be
doing
because once applications come to the
committee as
you know it's probably too late for all
that so more early work with developers
is
is definitely one of the things we
want to follow up and and do better
also just educating the whole um
the whole system in environmental
management is is
a system-based um program so
i think everyone from um you know pas
um offices planners all need to be aware
that
we have a biodiversity um priority now
and and what that means and i think we
will see
more active um proactive work
going on um which will improve
the biodiversity value of our
developments immensely because there's
huge potential there
on schools i agree with council award i
think we don't need to duplicate and
probably
we have to limit what we do and focus on
what we can do well
in terms of your comparison on page 35
i'll have to hand over to cass probably
to talk about that
if i could uh seamlessly pass on to will
if that's possible
as i know that he's got the answer for
that question thank you very much
yes councillor um the difference in the
discrepancy in those numbers is that
we've included that includes everything
in baber in open space down to the one
square meter whereas the mid suffix data
i think we started at about 100 square
meters and above um
so we have a lot more data that we
haven't applied but it was looking at
the
large areas first thank you
tonight jelly the reason i asked the
question
and suggested um we might be able to
download
um advice we can give to schools i just
wondered whether
um somebody like will could um
could suggest where we might find the
most useful information that
we as ward councillors can use when we
are talking to others
rather than we all look to download
something and it's all different
if there is a if there are you know
half a dozen half a dozen web sheets or
websites or fact sheets
that that would be useful um
yeah and thank um thanks to will for
that that answer so
so in mid-southwork are you going to
have a look at the
smaller sites or was there a reason why
you started that 100 meters upwards
i think it was just um the initial data
pack that we had it was easiest to work
with what we had but we want to
the same with the rest of the mapping
data for babe as well we want to try and
expand it to almost
to everything we've got to try and look
at everything we have as a package
thank you cass did you want to come back
on
anything there hi yeah i just wanted to
come back on uh the education part and
the question back to will there so
part of the campaign that's in the
action plan um
or the majority of actually sorry is
very much
um geared to what are the really small
things that you can do to make a
difference
whether that if you've got a large
garden or whether you've just got a
window box
there is something you can do that will
absolutely positively affect
the environment and and so it was about
making it meaningful for everybody
and including everybody so whether it's
literally planting a 20p
plant of lavender or whether it's you
know
changing the way that you you mow your
gardens uh you could see that you had a
really
beneficial and important part of that so
i think as part of that what
we will get is some information that is
available for schools and we can make
sure that they see that
and i think the aspiration past year one
will be to look at developing
further programmes that might be more
curriculum um
orientated but certainly the information
that we come out with
in the initial campaign that's suggested
in the action plan
i think we'll have lots of uh lots of
things that schools could take on
thank you thank you cass councillor
ebern
thank you very much um chair and can i
i'd say um
as well thank you very much to um
everyone involved with this because i
think
it's really great to see a very
effective short sharp
cross party group producing um such a
good report and obviously thanks to the
officers
and all the other external people
involved um
and i've got a couple of questions but i
can answer as well some of the questions
from other members because
in my area we've got eco churches
running which have done a lot of things
about
um biodiversity in churchyards and um
swift projects and so on and um
there's also a network of tree wardens
that takes on a lot of the work of of
checking trees some of those are aligned
to
parish councils and just in one of my
parish councils
we've had a biodiversity committee set
up for a while that's been looking at
where to plant trees where to improve
verges and so on so there's a lot of
things
i think are going on which um this
report builds on
but my question so with regards to the
budget i'm assuming from mid-suffolk
that
comes out of the general fund directly
and not the climate change the money set
aside
for climate change initiatives and have
we looked at
what the woodland trust grants are
because they provide grants for planting
trees and then my second question is
how um as i've said there's a lot of
work going on in
in um mine and counselor williams ward
um but how do we um get included perhaps
in this work sites
large sites that we've got within our
wards so for example in hawley the
scalisfield wood which
was once owned by suffolk county council
and is a very
um large area of land um
several hectares how do we get those
in to become part of this as it were
thank you very much thank you chair
okay um
thank you um i i think i might pass on
to cass to take the bulk of those
i i think um you can probably answer
better it's nice to see
the involvement of um of of the church
councillor eben and also
um i welcome you know i welcome your
constructive comments but cass can you
elaborate
absolutely and i was going to say as
well actually it's great to hear about
um the eco church's work i have
come across that actually uh so we will
certainly take that into account
um and also just to say that as i
understand it the
tree wardens group within mid suffolk is
uh held by height in high esteem by
suffolk county council as the best set
of tree wardens in suffolk so i think
there's a lot of learning
um that everybody can do from them and
because they clearly are
an excellent um group and the
budget question i'm not entirely sure um
i can answer that but perhaps i could
pass to finance portfolio holders to
answer that
but if i just move on slightly to the
grants
you're absolutely right the woodland
trust does have um
some grants on this and if i could
really bring in will birchnall
um will did a a lot of research on what
grants were available for tree planting
and as i believe it we didn't fit the
criteria for this but perhaps will could
you just elaborate on why
yeah we as local authority didn't fit
the
applicant criteria for woodland trust
that doesn't preclude the parishes from
doing it themselves
um i had a good meeting this morning
with members from
suffolk county council to talk about all
the things that we can do working
together
with their aspirations for tree planting
as well and there's lots of grants
around at the moment
and i'll try and collate that in our
next mail out to parishes when we talk
about tree and hedge planting
thanks for that i assumed that was the
case that we you know that maybe our
schemes were too big or
trees were too big as it were because um
they only provide very
um small saplings let's say so i i
thought that might be case but thank you
very much
for that and i'll i'll wait here back on
the the budget question
sorry could i just um clarify the final
point there you
were talking about other areas being
involved but i didn't quite catch that
i'm afraid
sorry yes um it was just if we've got
sites
um within our wards so um
and i mentioned an example in my ward of
a wood
um that was owned by suffolk county
councillors now owned by the parish
council
it how is it possible to get those sort
of included somehow
or or how do we um take on what's
happening with the task force into that
area as it were i see absolutely
yes so i think that um either through
the offices within the public realm team
or if the uh if it's agreed that the
task taskforce continues i think there's
absolutely
ways for any areas like that to be
brought into the work of the team
because we are going to have to generate
ongoing ideas and and look at other
areas that we can do
so local knowledge is going to be
absolutely imperative to that so
um i would be quite happy to start
taking
um comments on those kind of areas now
so we know
we can start planning ahead
thank you uh councillor whitehead do you
want to make any comment about the um
uh financial implications uh in answer
to custody burn
well my understanding i believe
is that 500 000 covered both climate
change and biodiversity but
i would say this is not a definitive
answer because i
i think we ought to get a bit of clarity
just to go back over the notes et cetera
to find to be sure about that
thank you thanks for that i can see
councillor maureen nodding as well so i
said
that might be the case councilor mccrore
you've got a question now
sorry double hit the button there uh
a couple of comments first thing is that
it's an excellent report has been
duly noted by everybody so
congratulations should go to the task
force
and indeed all the contributors and
there are a lot of contributors
one of whom uh principal ones is
actually an immediate neighbor of mine
so uh
i shall be congratulating that person in
due course um
i wanted to ask a more specific question
um along with the congratulations though
and this is about where
one species uh is clearly competing with
another
and i have a specific example in mind
but the general principle is that
if one species is crowding out this is
particularly true of plant life
and i'm thinking of a roadside plant
that i see all the time it's
very tall leggy uh with purple flowers i
believe it may be a species
of wood mallow lavatera but i could be
wrong
i'm not a horticultural expert and it
strangles the pavement it strangles
everything around it
and i wonder if the biodiversity
is being addressed by not dealing with
such infestations
because obviously the plant becomes
completely out of control
it reduces biodiversity so road
roadside flowers good but not all the
same and not if they dominate to such an
extent
that they kill everything else i wonder
if there's any thought being given to
that
um should i say yes
just please council flamingo because
castle mccrory is right with that
particular example
it um seeds freely and
it does once it takes a hold it it does
spread quite rapidly castle fleming
yes thank you um yes councilman mcgraw
you make an extremely good point
about the fact that not all um plant
species are very welcome sometimes
i think it may be purple loose stripe
but i'm not quite sure the one
you're referring to um
but one of the within the remit of the
biodiversity group is of course some
invasive species
and you know those are a huge problem
increasing problem in england in in
britain
actually our tree wardens are
exceptionally good about identifying
invasive species
and um as well as plant diseases
invasive
fungi etc not just ash dieback but
tree wardens can be very instrumental in
combating disease
so um i i think we need to
up our game in terms of being able to
identify invasion
invasive species when we see them and um
i'm not sure what the answer is but um
yes we need they need to be controlled
and removed so that our native species
can thrive
would you like a follow-up no no that's
that's fine it
really and i suspect it comes down to
individual cases uh
we know railway lines uh buddlier grow
incredibly in great profusion and that's
fine butterflies but
i'm just saying that not all growth is
good
is an important point to remember
that not all not all species can be
considered necessarily
equal no absolutely not and actually
japanese knotweed tends to be spread by
railways and and cutting um cutting
roadsides actually if it's around so
we have to be very careful to recognize
those um
bad species when we find them
okay thank you um councillor busby
you you want to come back with another
question do you
yeah you kind of cut me off in my prime
actually but uh oh
looking at uh the appendix a
we've both got in there 32 000 pounds
for inspection
um i thought we had already had in the
budget about 60 odd thousand pounds for
inspecting council trees this is is this
on top of the 60 odd thousand
or is it have we lost the sixty thousand
this is bringing it back
again so that's one question
if cassandra would like to answer that
sure would you like to come back
straight on there so this is
um in addition uh councillor busby to
the current
base budget for tree inspections so
whenever
we introduce tree planting we will need
to introduce an element of
maintenance and inspection revenue into
the base budget to support that
otherwise councils will just be in
trouble when we come to the end of year
and you'll see an overspend on
tree maintenance and inspection okay
uh onto the mowing um
you by doing the mowing and collect cut
and collect it's probably going to
double the costs of
getting the verges trimmed um
because it will take longer and they'll
probably need lorries etcetera to put
the
cuttings in and we use a lot of
contractors out in the villages will
they
need to have also replacement machinery
i mean
i think it's quite an expensive business
that we're
starting here
sure so um you're right
some of these things will have an
ongoing revenue impact without a doubts
but it's
the um the balance with the biodiversity
impact i think is
um necessary so this is
um for a pilot set so that cut and
collect mower
that was it is in within the budget for
this action plan
is for those trial areas so absolutely
if we were to look
to then roll that out across the
districts we would have to come back
with a business case that supported
exactly what that
whole impact would be and in terms of
the
collection it takes a little longer but
not as long as you think
and also part of the case study that we
saw and i'm so sorry but
the um the council was left my mind of
who
uh spoke to us about this um but they
found actually that there's quite a few
sites that they could use the trimmings
very close to where they were cut
to create new habitats so um it's not
just a case of
dumping your crimins over the fence
boundary clearly they've got to be put
in the right place and in the right way
but actually um we think that we can
create a plan that means that we use
that put those trimmings back into
another place that would help it does
mean that we will need to take some away
and we will have to uh get rid of them
appropriately
and that's part of that cost as well
okay
another reason for cutting the verges is
for safety reasons uh often junctions
are people are blindsided by tall stuff
growing in the verges
absolutely so um what this will not do
it will be
a full scale every verge anywhere you
absolutely have to take road safety into
account and you're right there is a
specific amount of
space back from any junction that verges
have to be cut no matter what
no matter what the habitat because of
vehicle safety so all of that absolutely
will be taken into account and finally
could we not
put a condition on uh new developments
where they we charge them a 10 pound a
house or something or
um i don't believe we can do that um i
know what's in our power at the moment
and speaking with my
colleague tom barker the assistant
director for planning and sustainable
communities he
has spoken about creating in the interim
and
um an advice um offered through to
developers on what they could do
but absolutely what we can do as the
public realm team is we are one of the
consultees on all planning developments
so we can be much smarter about the
advice that we give back and what could
happen on developments
uh that's different to their normal um
regimes
and i don't believe there is the ability
to put a charge on them for that
we put a charge on them for rams don't
we uh what i thought
i mean a developer's going to be pretty
mean-spirited
if we say look you're building a hundred
houses we want
10 pound a house a thousand pounds
towards a bio
diversity i mean what developer will say
no
well apart from persimmons perhaps and
one or two others
i would have to take that away for for
comment counseling
i don't think we can answer that one
just now okay thanks cass
one final question from counselor melon
yeah thank you chair um just a quick
question on the
um the cost of the trees which was
talked about earlier
um which i think came out as a was it a
purchase cost of 145 pounds a tree or
or did that include the cost of planting
and everything um
the reason for the question is um that
would seem to indicate we're talking
about planting much sort of larger trees
um and buying them in um at a bigger
scale
but i'm aware that smaller trees um you
know saplings
which are planted as bare roots tend to
eventually
out compete um larger planted trees
um and obviously they have a greater net
sort of
carbon uh sequestration effect so i'm
just concerned that
are we buying trees that are expensive
because of their immediate
amenity value rather than planting more
smaller trees for a longer-term benefit
yes bring in uh will on this because i
know we did a lot of work around what
those trees are
um is it what i will just say is
absolutely there is this sliding scale i
spoke of earlier so it's within our
guest
to choose what those trees are but well
if perhaps you could
talk in a bit more detail about why
those particular trees were put forward
initially
yeah so the um 145 pound trees
were for immediate impact but that gets
you a three metre tall tree
um in a region of um
10 to 12 centimeters in girth
grown in a pot planted and this was a
way of us being able to
put together the maximum budget figure
that we wanted for trees to be planted
and then
you're right there is a sliding scale of
trees and we can go
smaller but to get the the initial
immediate impact that we want
especially over a larger area we started
to specify with
what we actually wanted um and the best
we could go for
um when you come down to hedge planting
you're talking about planting
smaller whips you use six or eight per
meter you end up sort of temping
10 pounds a meter for a linear run of
hedge but
that initial figure of 145 gave us the
opportunity to scope
what we're wanting to ask you for in
terms of costs
okay thank you will right
um we've now gone through the questions
um i'm now going to
open up for debate but i'm conscious the
fact that quite a bit of the debate has
already taken place uh throughout the
questions
um so i will go through cabinet members
to see if anyone has any further comment
they wish to to make
um starting with the the baby cabinet
members
uh counselor arthi do you have anything
else you want to say in the debate
um well thank you yeah i suppose from
baber's side of the conversation
um we should recognize and um
be encouraged by robert lindsay's
contribution earlier on he is the the
leader of our
green group um and has been very
supportive
of the work of the cross council cross
party
task force and it's good to hear that he
welcomes these proposals for the
biodiversity action plan um i
um support the proposals i
will while i'm speaking just say dave
busby mentioned something
about developers and biodiversity
just encourage him to have a look at our
new jlp
and the biodiversity policy at lp 18
which if he reads through that talks
about measurable net
gains so i think part of what he's been
talking about although it doesn't re
i can't remember what he said 100 pounds
of property or something whatever it was
it doesn't talk in those terms but it
does talk about
the things that we can be doing to
encourage biodiversity on
new development thanks okay
thank you councillor busby any more
from you
no only well only just to say that as
part of one of the developments that we
did in worsted
um we asked for a
chunk of land to be put aside for moving
wildlife and trees too and
i guess grudgingly the developer
accepted that uh now of course we're
arguing about how big a piece of land
that is but
uh you know some some will do that kind
of thing
okay thank you castle davis
okay councillor holt
sorry i missed that i'm going to ask
david
i'm all good thanks okay counselor holt
yeah thank you john um all i'd like to
say really is
something that's been touched on
throughout the questions really and that
is the costing of it all
and how we as baber are going to find
the funds for it
um all cabinet members know we have some
difficult decisions lying ahead from a
budgeting point of view
and as much as the plan is an excellent
plan and well needed
um it's got to fit in line with other
priorities that we have
in and get in a budget pass so that
would be my only concern is that
um yes it's brilliant it's excellent we
need it but we do have to find the money
for it
yeah i totally agree council halt um and
that will be a challenge for us to
address
um councilman malvesi any further
comments from you
nope castle osborne sorry i was muted
okay and i don't have any okay thank you
councillor osborne oh yeah thank you mr
chairman um yeah no i think what i was
would have said
has already been raised but i do share
um councillor holt's concerns over how
we're going to finance this
um so yeah i do share that concern so
but otherwise i think it's it's
excellent thank you oh and just to say
um on another point um i have a previous
meetings raised the fact that
woods around town do have some mature
trees grown in their nursery that
they're going to make available to baber
although we can't have a site visit now
with the second locks down
of covid um i understand from
um the officers that they will be taking
us up on that offer so
that will make a little save and be a
small one but it will be a little saving
thank you mr chairman okay thank you
council oswald councillor parker
uh yeah no nothing that hasn't already
been uh raised
john really i you know we need to um
expand this conversation around
affordability for baber particularly but
nothing other than that at the moment
okay
thank you moving on to the mid-suffolk
members
um does uh council brewster do you have
anything you wish to add
i don't have anything i wish to add okay
counselor burn mr
um thank you uh chairman
um this is a discussion discussion
debate or um questions
uh it's debate okay um
the only thing i i i had that i wanted
to just contribute into the debate
it's just a little bit of understanding
uh for anybody who's concerned about it
and probably for any members of the
public who are
listening and watching in uh is
concerned with the hedgerow survey that
um
the answers to the questioning at the
beginning of this item were
not um not particularly
uh helpful in the sense that we didn't
know what the answers were
as to when they were likely to be
digitized the old
records um the only thing i would
add add to that is just to a piece of
information that these this was a
14-year long
survey that started in 1998
so that's why an awful lot of it
wasn't digitized at the time it was
actually carried out by
amateur botanists and and and farmers
with
with botanical knowledge uh and and they
worked along hedgerows in the field with
pieces of paper
ticking off boxes etc etc so
it's it's little wonder that 14 years
worth of
paper records are going to take a very
long time
to digitize and um uh
we we have to accept that i think
that's the only bit of information i
wanted to add to that one
thank you castlevan council flatman
uh no thank you chair nothing else to
add thank you
councillor fleming nothing further to
add thank you
councillor gould nothing further from me
thank you councillor haningham nothing
further i'm very happy to support this
thank you councilor morley
yes i've got something i'd like to add
uh chair thank you
um when i when i first moved into into
suffolk
um the first thing that i did was plant
over a thousand trees
and hedgerow plants throughout my
my plot and um
then i had to wait 15 years before any
of the trees were tall enough in order
to install my
my owl box but
once i installed my owl box in the first
season
i had a breeding pair in there and so
our biodiversity is so fundamental to
our enjoyment
of our places and where we live um
i've got pipistrel bats who live inside
my home
i even had turtle doves in the garden
which are an endangered species so
i am so fully supportive of all this um
uh actions in this action plan uh the
only thing i am really disappointed in
is that i don't have a hedgehog so
anything we can do to encourage hedgehog
hedgehogs
i am
it's got got to be a good thing so the
mapping is it
is so fundamentally important to
to the whole action plan because that is
what's going to tell us
where is going to be best to concentrate
all our efforts not only our financial
efforts but also our physical efforts in
[Music]
moving this plan forward i fully agree
with councillor flatman
that um schools should be involved um
i'm less
i'm less convinced about some of the
details that
councillor welum was arguing about
website search will will tell you how to
build a bug hotel
or a bat box or an l box um
i don't i'm not so sure that we should
be involved to that level of detail
as all that is in the public domain
anyway but
i fully endorse this report and i'd like
to really thank
the entire team who put this all
together it's a fantastic piece of work
and i'm going to be voting for it thank
you okay
thank you council molly castle whitehead
nothing further to watch here okay uh
thank thank you councillors um i i just
uh reiterate what everyone said that it
is an excellent piece of work and
everyone involved um
has has done a really really good job um
we've got uh an action plan sorry
council award may i just interrupt a
minute i think you've missed out
councillor
richard richardson i'm sorry he's not on
my list for some reason
counselor richardson that's no problem
thank you chef sorry about that
no worries no i'm just reading through
my um crib sheet here and you're not
you're not down
i've got i've got a couple of um points
i would like to make but i will be
cool because i know obviously we've been
talking for quite some time
um firstly i just want to say i
completely agree with what council
morley's just said
i think this is a really important
document and it's as a wider piece of
work i think it's really significant
for mid suffolk in particular i think
when i think about
suffolk and mid-south in particular i do
think it's synonymous with the beautiful
countryside those green open spaces
so i think this is absolutely integral
to sort of our identity as a
as a community so i think it's really
important but whilst as obviously this
document has
plenty of merits just on a pure
standalone basis
i think actually what's really important
is the way in which it's integrated with
the other strategic priorities we have
within our corporate plan
um so for example if i can give a couple
of instances there's the um
ability for um planning to draw on the
accurate information
that we will have as part of this
mapping to then be able to make better
judgments about
some of the development sites that
they're considering and i do think we
can
work with the developers much more in
the future in terms of increasing the
biodiversity in the green open spaces
within developments that we see in the
future eco tourism
is another one encouraging people to go
out and visit these these beautiful
places
and i think that's particularly ties in
very nicely with the new facilities of
needham lakes as well
so i think that's a sort of a brilliant
example of our different strategic
priorities working
hand in hand but obviously the one big
thing i want to talk about is
well-being and how important this is for
that particular part of our um
corporate plan because there are so many
ways
that you can measure general health and
well-being and access to
open spaces in the open countryside
there was a study i was just reading
over the weekend
um in the netherlands that showed for
every 10 increase in exposure to green
spaces
that translates into a reduction of five
years in terms of um
in terms of sort of expected health
problems so that's not
an extra five years in terms of overall
life expectancy but a five year sort of
reduction in the period where you would
have health problems
and that's sort of derived from the more
exercise you get just simple exposure to
vitamin d but also mental health as well
because there's also research um in a
growing science scientific field which i
wasn't aware of previously called
ecotherapy
that shows that there is actually a
strong connection between time spent in
nature and around wildlife and then
reduced
stress anxiety and depression but again
just touching on what
council flatman said as well really
important important point about schools
that in terms of improving people's
physical health
there's actually a really strong link
between access to nature and degree open
spaces and to
to that kind of immersion in the
countryside and exercise and then reduce
levels of obesity in in children and
young people as well
which i think is a really important part
of what will become our well-being
um strategy going forward so i think
this is a although it doesn't directly
touch on robbing necessarily i think we
should point out
there are in numerous um
additional benefits as part of this um
this piece of work so i really welcome
that and we'll be
absolutely voting in favor of it thank
you chair thank you council richardson
and uh yes from from my point of view uh
what everyone said it's it's a really
good
um starting point this document we've
got um some very good actions here
um and certainly something that um
as council gault has said is eminently
doable
and which can be built on um the the
point that
uh council of flatman made about schools
and uh getting them involved in council
fleming's
supported in terms of planting seeds i
think will help
certainly um uh with regard to trees um
the children can can watch them grow
right from
scratch and plant acorns uh
um hazel i'm not so sure about ash at
the moment with ash dieback but um
uh the the issue about um uh trees three
meter trees from immediate impact um
i think is is a bit problematic because
the the cost is is that much greater and
and council mellon is right
and planting smaller trees they do
quite rapidly overtake uh the larger
ones
um because the smaller ones once they're
established
um can can uh race away and grow quite
quickly so
um uh that we we do need to look at that
and um as as uh likewise with casa
morley i've planted quite a lot of
hedgerow here a number of years ago
about 15 years ago
um 18 inch whips soon maturing into
a very good um and wildlife rich
hedgerow so there's a huge amount of
benefit to be gained from that um
from from the baba perspective um
obviously
the the cost implications of this um
are problematic and we'll have to look
at it in as part of our overall budget
setting for next year
some of these items um uh are are
affordable with
with um uh use of our transformation
fund and and we certainly do need to go
ahead with
that the big one the the um the tree
budget is
is the most problematic and we probably
need to look at um
uh imaginative ways of trying to
undertake tree and and certainly hedge
planting
um and there's i think greater
biodiversity value from from hedges than
than from from trees perhaps but um we
need to look at that
but um we've got something uh really
good to go on
and finally um a green barrel site uh i
i
i think that's an excellent idea if we
can get one uh
or maybe two in in the districts um
uh it's is something that um uh
from a personal level i i think i i'd
find attractive although i i
don't particularly want to take up
occupancy for for quite a number of
years yet
but i think this
excellent document and probably tommy
moved to the vote
so um can i ask the governance officer
to conduct the vote please
chair may i just confirm that we've had
a second after each
uh yeah i seconded yes sorry yeah
yeah it's my apologies i'd have noted it
down
okay so counselors if um you could
answer before against abstain when i
call your name
uh counselor afi for
councillor busby four
if we can find the money davis
for councillor halt
four if we can find the money
councilmelvisie
four councillor osborne
four dependent on the budget
council parker four
councillor board four thank you and i do
i do take on board my colleagues
comments about the budget
councillor brewster
[Music]
four councillor byrne
councillor flatman four councillor
fleming
four councillor gould four
councillor huddingham four councillor
morley
four councillor richardson
four councillor whitehead four
[Music]
thank you chair that's unanimous thank
you
right um let's move on to item 10
which is paper bca207 the infra
infrastructure funding statement for
baby district council april 2019 to
march
2020 and paper mca 2007
the infrastructure funding statement for
mid suffolk district council april 2019
to march 2020. now these are on pages
47-132 for baber and 49-134
for mid-suffolk i'll now invite the baba
cabinet member for planning
to introduce the baba report counselor
arthi
thank you chairman can you hear me yes
great
okay um this is basically the same paper
paper going to both councils so
councillor byrne has asked
that mid-suffolk cabinet listen
attentively that's his word attentively
so that his introduction doesn't have to
be any longer than
absolutely necessary
as a result of last year's changes to
the sale regulations
we are now required to publish an annual
infrastructure funding statement
in simple terms this return to the
government says what we have collected
and what we've done with the money
it is for submission to government and
will be published on the council's
website
the ifs is in two parts appendix a
deals with collection and expenditure
and appendix b
with the delivery of infrastructure
projects
the infrastructure list in b replaces
the document you will be familiar with
up to now
as being our sill position statement
you'll also be familiar with the type of
information and data included
as this has been provided to cabinet
through regular and detailed updates
since we introduced the community
infrastructure levy
the headline 2019-20 figures
for baber are at paragraph 4.2
and you will see are that the
total sale income after deduction of the
admin fee
and neighborhood seal paid to parishes
and is 1 thousand pounds the total still
expenditure
is two hundred and ninety seven thousand
pounds
total section 106 income is 382 000
pounds
and total section 106 expenditure one
hundred and fifty thousand pounds
the total neighborhood sill allocated is
three hundred and twenty six thousand
pounds
and the total neighborhood sill spent is
twenty three thousand pounds
i want to express my thanks to christine
thurlow and the seal team
as you can imagine it has been a busy
time with the new ifs
the charges and installment reviews
which i will be presenting to council
tomorrow
and the framework review to complete
before the next bid round
christine is with us this afternoon to
answer any detailed questions you may
have
chairman i propose the recommendations
in the paper paragraphs
what 3.1 and 3.2 which provide for
appendices a and b
to be submitted to the government as our
infrastructure funding statement
and that they be published on our
website and i ask for a seconder
thank you thank you may i have a second
from baber please
i'm happy to second that john thank you
castle halt
right i'll now i'd like to invite the
mid suffolk cabinet member for the
uh for planning to introduce the
mid-suffolk report uh so councillor
byrne over to you
uh thank you chairman um yes and thank
you
councillor arthi uh for that
introduction which
as you rightly pointed out uh
differs very little uh from mid suffolk
and and in fact is uh uh
doesn't need to say an awful lot anyway
um you've heard that this is the result
of regulation changes that have been
imposed on us
that we've got to
produce this um
this this change in reporting and
uh those changes came in on the first
september
2019 and this is the first year in
or that was the first year in which we
were obliged to
um produce the
the infrastructure funding statement it
has to be
completed and submitted by the 31st
december
of course the figures in mid suffolk
differ from
those that you've just heard in in in
paper
uh they're in they're in um
they're in paragraph 4.2 of the report
but
i will uh just read them out for you
now the uh the total silly income
after deduction of the admin fee and the
neighborhood still so paid out
parishes was 4 million eight hundred and
fifty eight thousand
total sill expenditure uh this is in the
year 19
uh 2019 to 2020
um was uh
314 000 um
total section 106 income was 1 million
143 000 106 expenditure was 389
000 and the total neighborhood sale
allocated
was 848 000 and the total neighborhood
still
uh spent was 294
000 and um
counselor arty i i would like to
express my own thanks to christine
thurlow
and the sill team um who
i know have had an awful lot to contend
with
sill itself is not an easy uh
subject it's uh very complex
it's uh full of uh
it it needs a great deal of knowledge to
understand and apply it and
uh the team does extremely well
in um supporting any applicants any any
uh organizations that make bids for
for sale in exploring all opportunities
for
uh finding grants for them even if uh
silo106 can't come can't be
used so um i am more than happy to
propose the recommendations at
3.1 and 3.2 and
i ask for a second uh thank you thank
you councilman may i have a second
different mid-subject please
uh yes chair i'm very happy to
second the report um i
also would like to help the silk um
thank the seal team
for all their tremendously hard work
they get through
in delivering the seal out to our
communities
which is vital to provide the
infrastructure
and to support all the little local
projects that they want to
undertake so many thanks all round thank
you
thank you council flatman right i'm
going to open up
two questions now uh firstly questions
from baber members
um counselor arthur i guess you probably
haven't got any questions at this stage
casarthy sorry
no i haven't got any questions thank you
councillor busby
yeah thank you the demand notice i'm
looking at appendix a which is a
fantastic document
the demand notice um i can't see
anything
in there for the big
development in cable there's
money collected but it doesn't seem to
be anything
about a demand now the demand may have
gone out before i guess in 2008
which is why might not be in there i
don't know but
just is that the reason
counselor arthi are you able to answer
that
well quite plainly no i mean i could
open up the seal pages and try and find
it but all i'd say to
council busby is what we're looking at
today
is basically a statement of fact it's a
statement of of what happened in 2019
20. um if you've got any detailed
questions and you can't find the answer
for yourself on the sill pages
i'll gladly have a look for you or we'll
get one of the sill team to find it
okay thank you right
councillor davis no nothing to add very
good paper
thank you very much clive and the whole
team
council halt no fine thank you
councillor melvisi no thank you
councillor osborne no thank you mr
chairman just
to add that it is an excellent report
and well done to everybody involved
council parker uh yeah i will just uh
quickly share because um
councillor arthur is right this is a
statement of fact but i've picked out
from there um it's sort of highlighting
and i don't know whether we should be
reading anything into it or not but with
regards to the neighbourhood still
um in baby 326
000 pounds allocated to parishes but
only 22 000 spent
and i think my very rough mass is about
seven percent uh
that neighborhood suspense so um i know
we're not here necessarily to discuss
that but do we read anything into that
counselor arthi and
is there an argument that maybe board
members could be doing a lot more
to encourage uh their parishes to to
spend this money i mean
this is a fantastic um facility that
parishes have got here and
um in your opinion are we doing enough
i think it's uh it's all a timing
sort of issue um as you know we only
started collecting about four years ago
um and um you you and i were both
involved in the
in the framework that we set up before
sorry
everybody's still there yes
so yeah yeah you and i were involved in
the framework that we
we set up um with
um neighbourhood seal i have to say that
it
it tends to be the case in parishes that
they have to receive the money
before they can gather enough for their
projects
so although the number is quite large
um it's spread across the whole district
there are some parishes that have
received
quite a lot which has enabled them to do
things
there are other parishes who are how can
i put this accumulating
seal contributions and doubtless the
tipping point will come where they've
got enough
to be able to spend on the
infrastructure they want to provide
um and so as we roll through time in the
next year or two
um i'm expecting the amount of
neighborhoods still
spent to rise significantly
thank you thank you that's rathee um
right
moving on to the mid-suffolk members uh
castle brewster do you have any
questions
uh no mr chairman but i would
thanks to uh what's going on
funding statement is to my mind very
well
so i'd like to thank christine and the
members of her team including the cross
party uh
for all the background work that's gone
on thank you councilmember
so thank you very much uh
council byrne um i assume you don't have
a question at
this stage um council flatman
no nothing at this stage thank you chair
councillor fleming
um nothing to add thank you excellent
report
councillor gould uh nothing extra for me
just to share
everyone's appreciation of this report
and the hard work behind it
thank you councillor hanningham
yeah nothing for me like um peter just
said excellent work done
councillor morley no questions chair
thank you
councillor richardson i won't forget you
now thank you chad
no questions for me at this point thank
you and councillor whitehead
excellent detail report but no questions
thank you
right do any other members present have
any questions they wish to ask at this
stage counselor welum
your hand is up
thank you chair um just two very quick
questions which are slightly peripheral
um i see the um infrastructure uh
delivery plan is there
and it it's got one or two surprises i
just wondered
um whose responsibility is to
um to communicate the contents of this
to
the communities um because they were
thinking i didn't realize that there was
a proposal for a sto upland library in
there and that was
a bit of a surprise to me um and i just
wondered if
if it was somebody's responsibility
perhaps the county
to um to communicate its contents to
the communities and the other is um do
parish uh infrastructure implementation
plans
still have a role to play in the in the
whole seal process
okay thank you council welcome uh
councillor byrne
uh are you able to answer that i think
the um
infrastructure delivery plan is probably
not um something we
we should be debating under this
particular item but
castle burn um can you provide
well no i think you're right uh chairman
um
it it's it's not a part of uh it's not a
part of this funding statement
and um i think i'm happy to talk to a
counselor while i'm outside this meeting
on the subject
and and certainly um christine fellow
the uh
the manager involved would certainly be
able to
assist him on that one so thank you for
the question
uh councillor welland but we'll talk
about it later thank you
thanks thanks castlebern castlefield
yes um a long report obviously and uh
various points that one needs to discuss
uh not in this meeting
just one issue that did surprise me is
down on page
one two four um there's a statement
about
clayton high school and sporting
facilities the possible
extension there and i know the still 106
for that
has been around since blakenfield's
development
began so we're getting close to the
point where that money disappears and
evaporates
and yet i was surprised to find all the
statements somewhat non-committal and
you know there's no mention of there of
the cost i did recently push the
learning trust into producing some plans
i think or at least
one of their trustees and there's no
mention of
nothing there that looks like any form
of progress let's put it that way so
is that normal it's just
really or should i expect not to see
anything very definitive
we're talking about there's two hundred
thousand pounds available for that
extension uh which is going to cost
at least four maybe six hundred thousand
in total so
um it's it's a major project and would
have a big impact on health in the
in the area so
i i think council feel that probably
falls into the same category of
not really part of this particular paper
but um
certainly something that that probably
needs to be followed up um but
uh it's not really what what we're
debating here to today councillor byrne
did you want to come back
well except to say that i know that uh
christine fellow keeps a
a close eye on this and it we don't want
any
section 106 money
having to be paid back because we
haven't used it
in time just what we can do about it in
this particular
instance uh given
the uh the deficit if you like of the
total project
um i i i would not be able to say but
certainly i'm sure she's
she's uh she's present at the meeting
and and she will have
made a note of that and will uh respond
to it
um afterwards if that's all right with
you councillor field
thank you it is if i might just say i
think sometimes some of the bigger
projects here really do need someone to
pick them up and run with them
um you know there's large sums of cash
available
and we need to make sure it doesn't
escape
there's another 200 000 that goes for
the one i mentioned which
could very well be convertible for this
purpose so
it's something we need to pick up and
make sure it gets actioned
thank you okay thank you right
um for no further questions we'll move
over to the debate
section and firstly baba members
uh i'll go through each one of you
individually if you have anything else
you wish to
add to the discussion with this paper
counselor arthi no thank you chairman
i just asked cabinet members to support
the proposals
thank you thanks castle busby
well they have just been through the
education list of what's required and it
comes to 40 odd million
awful lot of money that we've got to
find from somewhere i'm not certain
still and section 106 is going to
provide 40 million
so i don't know what the county council
are going to do
um okay thank you
um council arthi did you want to respond
to that
um i'd love to chairman but i can't at
the moment i'm i was just
accessing the sill pages i'm thinking i
might have enough time to do that before
you asked me
um i was going to um give a figure
to councillor busby for the total amount
of sill that we've collected so far
um because we are talking very large
numbers here
um and we've also um got a whole load of
sill that's expected on approved
development which
i don't know if councillor busby
accesses his sill pages
at all but whilst i've been talking i'm
just hoping that i've given somebody
like christine enough time
to access the seal pages herself
and she might be able to just give us
that figure are you there christine
i am but i've struggled to get the um
the database to play ball with me so i'm
sorry about that
yeah okay well i'm struggling in just
the same way but we can get that answer
for councillor busby quite simply i mean
the the point is um the council of
busbee that
we are talking about very large amounts
of money providing significant
amounts of infrastructure moving forward
yep okay thank you
council davis you know i'm glad to hear
that
we're providing this money for
infrastructure as well because
we all know the biggest complaint we get
or the planning committee gets
is about the infrastructure we're
building the houses but not the
infrastructure
but at the same time i echo um
councillor busby's point about their
education
because i do worry that some some
schools especially the academies that
are supposed to be self-funding
are looking to dip into this part as
well so i've got a bit of mixed feelings
on that one but overall
great paper and that's pretty much all i
want to say
thank you councillor halt yeah excellent
paper
uh i echo uh council buzzer and
councillor dave's
concerns re um the extra the large
expenditure that we
that we're looking at and also touching
on that that we're not the sole
contributor to those projects those type
of projects either this is a
still contribution towards bigger
projects which
also need partners to contribute as well
um
and and touching on what council parker
mentioned earlier um i think there is
some
some leeway in that or some movement in
that we could give
possible possibly by sending out some
sort of information like a newsletter to
parishes because i
i take cancer arthy's comments that
perhaps they're saving for bigger
projects but there is time limits on
this still money
and they i'm sure most of them are aware
of it
but i don't think they really
are signing into it in as much as the
money's there they need to use it and
fund projects that that are within their
parishes
and also we've touched on it as well
in in council that baber again as an
authority need to tap into it as well a
bit more
wisely than perhaps we've done so in the
past so i certainly think that there's a
little bit of um
something we can do with with parishes
to try and encourage them
to use the money for certain projects
and
possibly think no no i don't know
think of that out of the box possibly as
to what they think they can do with the
money
i think there's there's some there's
some work there to be done i think
thank you okay chairman could i just
say since it was mentioned again i've
accessed the um the
sill pages now um and
if i can just give you the total figures
um
the the potential column um has got just
over
15 million pounds in it um
due so that's where work has started um
and we will be collecting
um that's just over four and a half
million pounds
and the amount collected to date is just
under six million pounds so that just
gives you an idea of the
the types of numbers that we're talking
about
and remember that the infrastructure
that we're planning for
and the the costs associated with that
they're going to be coming out of the
pot how can i put this
when it's bigger than it is now
yeah thank you um council malvisi
thank you no i don't have anything to
ask okay
councillor osborne thank you mr chairman
yeah just very briefly
um i agree with perhaps the um
lack of the applications from town and
parish councils but i think also
there's a lack of actually understanding
what they can apply for so i think when
we look at this we need to look
look at the website i know there's an
awful lot of information on the website
but is it in layman's terms for town and
parish councils to understand so i think
we need to look at that as well to make
sure
that we are providing sufficient
information and that information
is um easily understood if you like
uh by our town and parish clerks thank
you mr chairman
okay thank you councillor parker
um no no no particular extra points
i will just say um chair that um i've
been part of the
the seal working group right from the
beginning and um and it's been an
absolute pleasure to
to be part of something that really does
deliver real
real value back to communities um and um
i shall continue banging the drum
to make sure that our parishes know
about it and understand it fully thank
you
thank you okay moving on to the mid
suffolk members
council brewster
mr chair i do sympathize with
this is being held by the parish
councils and then
um goes to them
into the 15 or 25 percent
it does seem an awful lot still being
held
up used and obviously there is up there
but i think we could do something
thank you councillor uh you did break up
quite a bit there but i think we got the
gist of
what you were trying to to say about the
um
uh the parish council element um
right uh council councillor
do you have anything further to to
contribute to or should i move on to
your colleagues
um thank you thank you chairman i uh you
caught me on the hook there i was trying
to look up some information
um no i don't at this stage uh as
as as as counsel arthy said uh
this is all largely a statement that
well entirely
a statement of fact and it's something
we have to do so
um i'm happy that we should just get on
and uh yep
okay thank you castle flatman
um just to say that i do know that the
town and um parish
um councils do have training training
every so often on sale so
and i know a lot of the clerks have been
there quite a long while so i think most
of them have had the training on this
yeah that's true yeah thank you chair
councillor fleming
thank you chairman um yes i i do think
maybe the training needs to be um could
possibly be really looked at
um for parish councils especially in the
area of
how they can um pull sill and and
join together to um bid for
larger amounts of money for possibly
larger projects
um that's all quite legitimate i'm not
sure many of them know
really how to do that or communicate
with each other enough
so there probably is a role for us to do
more to to help to put that money to
good use but
it's a really good report and um apart
from the odd bus stop that's still in it
um it's you know well done
thank you castle gould thank you very
much uh
chair uh again echo the comments of of
others in
in in approaching the report and and
turning
a very uh complex subject in into
something that we can
uh question in the way that we in the
way that we are
um i think it's been interesting in
terms of the
uh understanding of of
parishes in this and i've seen my own
parishes move from uh downright cynicism
when it comes to
the provision of infrastructure through
a suspension of disbelief
uh into starting to cut along to the
fact that
actually still is there and it is
delivering uh projects
uh for their communities and and uh
very much getting the hang of it now i
think and but as as council fleming says
i think there's a role
for us to play in in in relation to that
but um again applaud
all of the work that the team does uh
and
in the production of this statement
which i shall support thank you
thank you councillor hanningham
um thank you um i just want to say that
um while i appreciate that the money is
often spent
in towns and key service centers i was
really pleased that bringfield barnes
was successful in their bid because um
um
i think something like a day nursery
really makes hamlets like wingfield more
um
desirable places to live and helps keep
them viable
and um and the project will contribute
directly and indirectly with
our own mandate for safer stronger and
healthy communities
and um the increased football um and
visitors to the site will encourage more
use for the centre for arts and
exercises
and um an increased income as a whole
will make the whole thing more
sustainable and i just want to say
they've already found a tenant for the
nursery and um and the building work is
due to start mid-december
thank you thank you councillor morley
thank you thank you chair um i i think
it's
fantastic this um this sill report
it's looking backwards so it's all a
statement of fact
um and it's very thorough very detailed
but also on top of that i would really
like to commend
to everybody our um
developer contributions database which
is online so every councillor whether
you're
a district council a county councillor
parish councillor town councillor
everybody can get on and look at the the
uh database
online and see what is available there
um and and all our clerks do have
training in this
it may have been a bit patchy over the
last seven or eight months
for obvious reasons but um all the
clerks have had training
they know how to use it and they know
how to apply
for it there was something that somebody
said earlier
about sil contributions expiring
i didn't believe that was true section
106
contributions are time limited but i
didn't think still was
so perhaps christine thurlow could
um clarify that outside of this meeting
thank you i think it's fantastic i'm
going to be supporting it okay
thank you councillor richardson
uh thank you very much chair um i'd just
like to make a couple of points if i may
um firstly just to echo what everyone
else has already said
um over the course of this meeting that
it's obviously it's a fantastic report
um so i'm very grateful to officers
who've put what is obviously an enormous
amount of time and effort into this
specifically and at the risk of sounding
like a broken record um i think
some of the contributions that's within
this document particularly around
leisure and sporting facilities are
incredibly important
um so just to give a few examples of
what we've already supported
so extra playing fields in mendelssohn
and play area refurbishment in woolpit
a gym trial in thurston improved
crickets and football facilities in
in norton um so i think that's that's a
really important aspect of what sil can
actually
deliver for our communities and that
sort of touches upon what i was talking
about
on the previous gender item
in particular though i think given the
year that we've had and given the fact
that daily exercise was an explicit
part of both the first lockdown and the
current lockdown it shows the importance
of
being able to access those sporting
leisure facilities for people's
physical and mental health
well-being and in particular what i
would really hope to see is because
of the well-being strategy that we are
going to implement as as both councils
is i would like to see because we've all
i think seen and heard
anecdotal evidence around people using
the lockdown as a sort of opportunity to
go out and
go for more walks go for go for runs go
for for bike rides and i'd really like
to see those sorts of trends continuing
and i think that's what we can do as
as a district council via our um
investment in infrastructure is really
support people to do that
and i certainly know that during after
the first lockdown over the summer
i um found myself going out cycling a
lot more than i used to
um you know making use of those
wonderful countryside
scenes although i will confess that some
of those cycle rides did involve going
to and from the pub but i like to think
that was uh
doing my bit to support my local
businesses as well um
but i think that's a really welcome
aspect of the work that we've done
there's also one other thing which i
just wanted to touch upon um
which is a relatively small aspect of
this overall report but i think it's
something i care passionately about
which is um palliative care end-of-life
care so i used to work as a carer
at st nicholas hospice and various
integrity so i was really pleased to see
that the
one aspect of the sil contributions was
for increased provision and specifically
palliative care
at bottasdale um health center because
there's a there's been an
enormous shift um in terms of of
end-of-life
um policy over the last few years which
has
deliberately tried to shift the emphasis
out into the community
um because that's what for end-of-life
care patients that's what they want they
want to be able to be cared for
and to be able to ultimately die at home
so i think being able to support
um the health and social care system do
that i think is really important so
it's not necessarily going to be the
thing that we hear an awful lot about
but i think it's actually a really
important bit that we can contribute to
because historically and i'm not going
to go on into too much detail but
obviously historically
palliative care has reliant has been
reliant very heavily
um on the voluntary sector so doing our
bit as a as
a as a local authority and helping our
communities is something that i would
really
really welcome so i think although
that's a small point is one that i
am quite passionate about so for for
that and many other reasons i will
definitely be supporting this thank you
thank you councillor richardson totally
agree with that um councillor whitehead
do you have anything you wish to
to add at this stage i'll just say for a
great such great amount of detail in the
report
excellent report um i suspect quite a
few of the parachutes are just taking
the opportunity to
build up a war chest you know as the
various small developments windfalls
come through
so we will see it spent fairly soon and
my recollection when silva was first
being introduced in terms of education
was that
it was always going to raise quite a
decent amount of money it was always
going to be a relatively
modest sum relative to the total
infrastructure
needed uh you know in the district so
every little helps um so that's all i
have to say thank you
okay thank you um councillor byrne
did you want to say anything more at
this stage
um yes i just wanted to reassure
councillor
morley that um the conversation that uh
councillor field and myself were having
uh concerned section one of six monies
not cell monies being um
unspent uh or unused and and
uh on the point of having to be returned
so it wasn't until we were talking about
is section 106.
um the other point is and i'd like to
bring um
christine furlow in here is our comms
strategy requires us to
uh do a certain number of briefings
uh this is in connection with um
talking to parish councils etc uh
perhaps she could explain
what exactly that strategy is and and
how we
discharge it
christine uh thank you
yes um our comm strategy does indeed say
that we will provide
uh briefings both to members but also to
uh town and parish councils each year uh
normally twice a year and in the past
we've been very
active and proactive on that front
uh this year things have been very busy
obviously covid has interrupted um
us doing our normal thing so to speak
but it is my intention
to get on top of that and to roll out
some virtual briefings
which we can do with the parishes to
refresh them on matters such as the
infrastructure funding statement
all the changes that there are but also
to
to refresh them on all matters still
because as members have identified there
is a lot of money
out in the communities now and some of
the parishes
are contacting us and asking for
help to do a pip which is a planning
infrastructure investment plan which
identifies what infrastructure
priorities the parish may have
and then we can look at how
collaborative spend
can achieve that or indeed to to look at
some of the projects which
are we're already active with with them
in terms of trying to
give them some sort of funding strategy
about how to deliver
what they need so uh i'm sure looking
forward
that's something that we can put in the
diaries and bring everybody
up to speed on thank you okay
thank you for that christine well um
that
has been a useful debate uh members of
the two cabinets
um i think i like over what everyone
said great report
and and thanks as usual to christine and
the team
uh they they always do a superb job uh
for us
with um and still so i'll now
move uh to the vote and ask the
government's officer to conduct the vote
please
thank you chair once again members if i
could ask you to say
um fought against or abstain when i call
your name
alfie four
councillor busby councillor davis
poor councillor halt four
councillor malvesi four
councillor osborne four
councillor parker four council award
four thank you chair that's unanimous
and mid suffolk councillor brewster
four councillor bern
[Music]
councillor flatman four councillor
fleming
four councillor gould four
councillor hattingham or
richardson four and councillor whitehead
four thank you chair once again that's
unanimous
thank you right moving on to item 11
and this is the resolution to exclude
the public um and that it
includes the press so to consider
whether pursuant to part one of schedule
12a of the local government act 1972 the
public should be excluded from the
meeting for the business specified below
on the grounds that if the public were
present during these items
it is likely that there would be the
disclosure to them of exempt information
as indicated against each item the
author of the report proposed
to be considered in part two of the
agenda is satisfied that the public
interest in maintaining
the exemption outweighs the public
interest in disclosing the information
i would like to propose this may i have
a sector from baba please
second that john clive thank you council
arthi and
uh may i have a proposal and secretary
from mid suffolk how do you propose for
miss suffolk thank you castle whitehead
and the second
i'm happy to um yeah thank you counselor
hannigan
right and i now ask the governance
officer to conduct the vote please
thank you chair councillor alfie for
councillor busby four councillor davis
councillor halt four councillor mal bc
four councillor osborne four
councillor parker paul
council award four key
councillor brewster four
councillor burn four councillor flatman
four councillor fleming four
councillor gould four
richardson four councillor whitehead
four thank you chair that's unanimous
i'll just wait for rob to confirm that
we are now
you